by GQ is the bar oh I don't know what I
did my hands
we're a lion Rudy you know us is food
Beast oh my god the steak just melts GQ
centers across the country to find the
best cocktails food and bars around
you're watching where's the bar
what's up dude where are we right now
we're in Seattle this is Capitol Hill
specifically Nick is the bartender here
at Bar naka and I heard he has a built
drink for us so we're gonna check it out
let's go knock on the door it's a pool
fire code at the Q pool Nick welcome
what's up to you it's so good - lets go
is good welcome to Seattle here it's the
first time I've never been here my last
year I don't remember and I wasn't an
adult so don't count it it totally
counts you're a baby it's an impression
on who you've come today oh this is so
deep soul I love it this Capitol Hill
though right this is like yeah Capitol
being the heart the pulse of Seattle so
it's kind of hard to encapsulate to one
word right so in the same moment you can
go to a riverbed or forest same thing go
snowboarding you go to the beach and the
weather is so as creative as we are
so it's suits friend right now it's
turning sunny it's been done it was
raining last night I'll probably have a
tornado tomorrow knock on fruit and we
are I think just hitting the cusp of
getting national recognition from almost
every angle so Seattle was very small
like a fishing town right compared to
New York
yes I'm Cisco right the transition of
the Renaissance of cocktails is moving
stuff to the forefront the hospitality
is kind of better the fourth degree
yeah it's cultures but Seattle is
definitively the Grunch right have like
I love our guide bars so unicorn will go
there later so you see the transition of
clothing right it's not bow ties and
more like cufflinks or weird things
rather than study a pre-prohibition the
drinks and the cultures the internal
advocacy oh that's true yeah but the
style we have to move with it we've got
in the history bit about this yeah what
what are you making
gotcha we call it the Gospels garden so
that's a really fun interactive and it's
a plated cocktail and we'll get to what
that means in just a second we're still
a little bit of Bombay Sapphire
okay so our botanical edge it's a lemon
dry and this will be a play on a sour so
we're gonna have a city in there from
lemon whenever you make a cocktail keep
it balanced so whenever you have that
acid that have a sugar component to calm
it down and make it like dance
that's me our ginger syrup yeah done so
now this is our base template good to go
we're gonna do the addition of egg white
charcoal solution and then Scrappy's
firewater teacher so it's a great tie
backs like why Seattle is represented in
this content well so it's gonna be a
little interesting when you see the
color and the taste yeah the external
vision will be a little different than
out taste that's why I think Seattle's
best understood yeah like it's cool to
drink charcoal right always ya know it's
actually beneficial so it's almost like
a net neutral cocktail but I'm not a
doctor so you can't quote I've got a
scientist so it will make you sick but
it won't make you better
well the fun parts like you remember
what it is to taste god I smell gas
tastes liquid and feel what is neither
so the charcoal actually adds just a
textural sensation right there's no
volatile aromatic in it okay that's a
crazy part yeah so now we got everything
going dance [ __ ] and the fun part
I will the play made cocktail and we're
gonna go I don't think I've ever seen a
plated doctor like neither of I this
means chef during the first couple weeks
before we open we'll put up two cutting
boards and look at glassware him from
not a background of cocktails but also a
huge garnish master and watching him
work with it it inspired me in a lot of
ways so I saw his food and realized the
intensity that he goes into the holistic
aesthetics I would say kind of brought
this cocktail to light so when I think
about classic cocktails in the sense of
a Manhattan in an old fashioned these
all have garnishes they're all beautiful
but how far can you push a garnish so
that's what I'm doing here I've never
seen a sour of this dark this is a
strange to see right that's me a light
of the deception now so just maintain
the idea this hours always top garnish
nice and simple
I'm a gentleman this has been the
Gospels garden make a wish to do some
sort of ritual
I've yeah I feel like remember to call
your family that's it that's there's a
external part of the car can I text them
I count my cats it's our generation baby
oh nice - its dark and gloomy like the
weather but then like it's nuanced and
actually refreshing at the end like a
sour which is like how I feel every time
I'm meeting someone new I hear you've
somehow incorporated that and encompass
that in this drink
it tastes way different even it looks
kind of sour and tart and sweet we gotta
get in Ella so you know take a walk
think water ops come into our bars yeah
it's all good yeah it's we're very happy
people small but proud nation well you
have to drink but my tummy's rumbling
yeah what's good visit mr. chef shuttin
he'll take care of you to the kitchen
alright gentlemen welcome welcome
welcome to introduce you to our dear
beloved chef showed up what's going on
so today I'm using a few local
ingredients a lot of seafood because
that's what Seattle's about today I'm
doing the sashimi which is also called a
channel a cat not good that makes sense
pretty much what we do for garnish is
red kelp a little bit of julienned
daikon we do this all by hand
and then a piece of [ __ ] silly and then
we have something bluefin from Spain
right here it slip belly cut it's not
the belly belly it's right next to the
belly so it's fatty but it's not too
belly not full [ __ ] so it has the nice
red meat flavor but you get the fat
content with it so it's balanced out
well well that's just fish on the side
how does this kind of like speak to what
what's going on in Seattle and how does
it tie into the history of Seattle
itself has a lot of great seafood but no
one's really using it to its full
potential using a lot of local
ingredients showcasing of what we got
and bringing our seafood to our full
potential so I guess what is this I mean
you are all out to
oh my god man you just let the fish
shine that's what that's down that's
awesome
today we have some super French black
cod as well is that what's going on
behind me it is it's what's keeping you
hot I'm gonna pull it off
yeah all right chef I'm really nervous
about where I shouldn't you're supposed
to drop it oh just drop it not like that
not like that once there's a lot of our
most popular dishes lots underneath the
sheeter and then a simple marinated
black cod grill butter here and then we
do smoke in it because is one of the
biggest senses so when you get it it's
not just eating food it's the creation
it's everything so you get to enjoy the
plating to get to enjoy obeying it then
you get enjoy the whole night oh my god
this skin is awesome holy cow the fish
what do you what's on it anything we
play and then we cured with comas all
for one night okay then we let it air
dry with it skin side up for one hour
look good after that we marinate it for
one night with a little bit of sake soy
mirin take it out and then you let it
air dry so the aminos go around again
and then get the skin side up and then
we grill it so this has been days in the
making
you could taste every single one of
those days in in this fish that's insane
so that's kind of how I look at food is
you look at integrate in and not coating
it with anything but how do you get the
full potential out of things yes but
that's a little taste in Seattle what we
do is the next generation you'll
probably see more overcoming if you're
in Seattle roll to Capitol Hill you got
to come to NACA
put your trust in in these boys man
literally boys they're 26 and 27
Thank You chef thank you she that was
fantastic man it was like we got a crazy
drink from Nick and we got an awesome
taste of fall in Seattle with fresh fish
I'm pretty sure that's actually like the
best piece of fish on the right yeah let
Nick let sure take care you guys